>>> ANE BLICAN PRESICANDIDATE A
VEHRESU U RE
N RATHERN  CRITICISM.
WE SHOULD NOHAEOPLE T ER
SKEPTICAL OF THIS BE
YOU DROPPED OUT IN TU
>> YOU RAN HIS TRANSITION AND CD
PL KNOW,S GUY HAS
CH YMI YOU KNOW, BKEITE NOMINEE.
I HAD HAD A LONGHIP
RNS S WRONG. I RAN IND IULD HEL
ERDNA DENT ANDSAPPOINTED ME, AND
DISAPPOINTED A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
HE
POINWAECTION N
WHE 0 IN
THYOU HAVE FORFEITED THE IN
NOW TRYIN
REGAIN D
OS
W R THEM,
I'LL ADD KNIT AND I THOUGHT I
RESPONSE TG RAN UMP LAST NIG
RATHNGSOAL
MEA.ER DISH GUES
FUN OF YOUR WEIGHT.
TH HIS- BEU MAKEAT TI SAW, IT
RENEWED IN MY  WA
CHILD HE IOUT TO CRITICIZE
WA RESPOS, ANDN AN
ENOUGH TOE
HAD A CHILD LVWEO  NE.
CTER IY FOTH COUNTRY, WE'VE GOTT
CAN YOU EVEN SAY ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THAT TY DICK
LOANTOREAK NEW
HERE T,  STRUGGLED WITH
W YEARSKENS OYOU SAY. LY, SO HA
NEWSHE'S TELLING PE SOMETHING
THEY DON'T
ND F ME, IT'ABYOPE PERSON.
>> YEA OU ,
PUT MIN HIS
ANY DAY >> SO ON THEJECTU AD
PRETTY CANDID LAS OF THE
MISTAKES IN YOUR S
TO PLAY  OF TH--
A BRIDGE SCANDAL.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND TRUG OPSHOULDN'T HAVE TR
ALSO -- YOU ADD MI S
TONE THAT THOS
BE SOMETHING  YOU WOUD ACABMIT
THAT.
>> IIDAT WHOW ME AND
>>UT VERARD,ECSELF
REGULARLY IN ARAD DEMOCRATICAN
SO YOUT  KINDS
OF THINGS AND THINHACOIS
S GOVERNOR.H THE NA
PREST, THE SPEAK. PIFT
LEGISLATION, GOTUN
JUDGES APPOINTEDNCH.
REFORM.
>> YEA PROPETA THIS OPLE N TLD
>> SORRY T
CAREFUL. SEL>> THAT YOO VEN MORE
THERE'S NO INSIGNICA
NO INSIGNIFIE SOE
ERU ,
THEY ARE DISPANT FROM YOU LIKEWE
DISTANT FROM YOU, I THINK ERE'S
WT WILL BE FINE ANDU .
IT WAS A MISTAKE.
DE A M IN
JUDGMENT, HORRIBLE MISTAKE IN
JUDGMENT.
THEY P
>>O D THEREOMISSUES YOU
TH'MY CURIOUS ABOUT,
THE PGA TO
BYDI GOVERNMENUSD ITS
RECORD.
11S Y.
PGA OWINWILF.R REACTION?
>>U OFF AIR.S UN NEWS LAST NIGH
WAS ABSOLUTELYP AIL HEARD FROM
WEREE HAONBUT I GUESS THE SAUDI
WITH ENOUGH MONE OVERRIDE
MO PRINCIPLE,
AN IL REALLY BAD
WHO STOOTH ON THAT
-F ANDOW GOING HAVE TO AY WITH
>> RIGHT. THINK THE PGAHOSE
AN ENORMOU PROBLEM ON
ST FOR OWNERSANCE  INTERESTING O
TH TO NA RS LAUNCHED THIVISION .
AS YOU KNOW, TWO OF YOUR OME TE
TR SAY IN THE
TOWN HAL KAITLYN,
ND RS UTE.S TO VLADIMIR N R
AT
ON
EY
THIS IS A PROXR  CHINA.'S WHAT E
NO OE IN T W
THEY ARE FUNDING T MUR
UKIN BIDENT XI GOES TOANDS WITAN
THS  CSE
FRE RUSSIANS.
IF YOU'T UNDERSTAND THAT  BGEJU.
GOING TO SEE DWE  OUR FRIEND ANO
EM FROM
THISXCTHS OPINION A PUPPE     A.
S BEEN DWEOUARLY ABOUT
VLADIMIR PUTUR
THAT HE PRESIDENT, AND I EREDO
>> SO SO MANY MORE WE'RE OUT
.
L SAY, AS YOOW
I'VE WANTED U TO COME AND AN LO,
LOT NTRACT